[Musique]
c'est mon auberge vient de passer à
l'histoire
samedi l'athlète américaine égalait le
record du plus grand nombre de médailles
remportées en championnats du monde de
gymnastique encore de 23 médailles
établi par le bélarus vitaly charbo 24
heures plus tard secondaire briser cette
marque en remportant à la poutre sa 24e
médaille mais la gymnaste de 22 ans ne
s'est pas arrêté là
sa performance au sol lui a valu une 25e
médaille
chez nous les exploits de ces mondes
base ne sont pas passés inaperçus
seaman bas elle est au même niveau que
les usain bolt ou lequel sidney crosby
les deux membres de l'équipe nationale
américaine depuis l'âge de 14 ans ce
monde base est aujourd'hui considérée
comme la gymnaste dominante de son sport
cinq fois médaillée olympique des jeux
de rio certaines figures acrobatiques
porte même son nom la championne
canadienne de gymnastique zoé a l'air
bourgi rêve de suivre les traces de
l'américaine qui elle a eu la chance de
voir à stuttgart
c'est vraiment une gymnastique km des
manières et d'une poussée c'est vraiment
comme un exemple qui me permet de venir
d'angela chaque jour les m'entraîner pin
et me pousser pour vraiment essayé
d'espérer atteindre un niveau que l as
l'entraîneur catherine dussault constate
l'importante progression de ces mondes
bearers au cours de la dernière année
un dépassement de soi qui peut servir
d'inspiration ou plus jeunes de réaliser
que même simone même s'il était
exceptionnelle elle a dû travailler le
dû contrôler ses nerfs elle dut faire
face à la pression
elle a dû aller au bout d'elle-même pour
hervé à perfectionner ses performances
ce monde banque contribue aussi à faire
briller la gymnastique féminine souvent
sous-estimé à démontre que ça peut être
aussi spectaculaire que la gymnastique
masculine fait que ce soit que nous
comme entraîneur des jeunes à ces
criminels
on est fier de ça il y à fort à parier
que ce monde base nous réserve d'autres
exploits pour les jeux de tokyo en vain
et si valérie niquet a et la b
une radio canada montréal